- Hi My name is Jeff Cheen,
I'm the chief coffee
guy at Groundwork Coffee
and this morning we're
going to try one coffee,
brewed over several different methods,
and discuss the differences we taste
that those methods
bring out of the coffee.
Come on in to my playpen, lets go.
(playful music)
- I'm Lizz, I'm an artist,
so I drink a lot of coffee
from all over the place.
I'm not an expert but I do taste a lot.
- I'm Jeff, chief coffee guy,
guess the resident expert, so.
- I'm kind of the coffee
snob around the office.
- I've worked with coffee before.
I've worked at a couple
different coffee shops.
So you could say I have a professional
relationship with coffee.
- I talked a lot of coffee game
and I'm kind of here to
see what I actually know.
(playful music)
- [Jeff] This is the Chemex brewer
developed by a very bored chemist
who was up late at night
during World War Two.
[sipping sounds]
- Jeff I did not like that one.
- Clean coffee flavor.
- It's like shitty diner coffee.
- [Jeff] This is called
the Clever Dripper.
This is a full-emergent brewing.
- Shoe taste like a little shoe.
- Yeah, I would say
yeah not a lot of power,
did you taste some shoe in there?
- Tasted some shoe.
- That was kind of boring,
- [Lizz] Not a lot of flavor.
- [Jeff] yeah softer edges.
- [Laura] It's a little flat
- [David] Rich, but not bright
- like a Beverly Hills housewife.
- [Jeff] French Press, you've
seen this around every where.
Got a very, very full-body taste.
- [David] It's orangish
- It's more of an amber.
- Yeah, you're absolutely right.
- I wouldn't be surprised to find
like an ancient mosquito in here.
- I think this is the french press.
- I could drink this black.
- [Jeff] Alright, this is the control
that we're going to use,
this is a Mr. Coffee
made famous by Joe DiMaggio.
- I'm tasting some soil, is that normal?
- This I'll say is shitty.
- I felt this is definitely the
darkest of the three so far.
- Tastes like it wasn't
extracted properly.
- I'm going to say these two are watery,
this is the boldest for me.
- [Jeff] Pour-over V60, it's Japanese,
Japanese culture has a long
history of love with coffee.
- You got a gray dangle.
- That's the wangle of my dangle.
- It's like good or diner.
- I've felt like kind of
watery, not very strong.
Left me again with a
little bit of a flat line.
- Leaves a nice flavor in my mouth.
- I'm getting a little
flavor, it's a little heavier.
- Okay, Well I'm obviously correct,
so where did you go wrong on
this taste thing right now?
- [Jeff] Aeropress, is made by the guy who
made the Aerobie Flying Disc.
- It tastes kind of like burnt coffee.
- I could sense coffee but
mainly like the shadow of coffee.
- It's coating the tongue,
but it's not really livening
up the party, right?
- It didn't hit me like a punch.
- Alright watch that
major skin of the game,
because again I talk a lot of
coffee game at Buzzfeed so.
- So this is a potential source
of huge embarassment for you.
- I'm liking this one the best.
- So again this was my favorite.
- I'm sticking with my french press
and Mr. Coffee choice.
- [Voiceover] There you go, correct.
- Oh shit (laughter)
- [Jeff] Yeah sorry Joe.
- French Press or Chemex.
- I just really hope he picks Mr. Coffee.
- [David] No
- [Laura] What, which one?
- [Voiceover] Mr. Coffee
- [David] No
- [Laura] Did you pick Mr.
Coffee as your favorite?
- No (slow motion voice)
this is my favorite.
- This is, you've messed up,
you have messed up with your order.
- Wow, David your such a pleb,
- [David] Oh, man.
- but you didn't even know it.
- My life has been up ended.
The fact that I chose
Mr. Coffee as number one
is ridiculous.
(playful music)
- [Laura] You going to walk off set now?
- [David] No, I'm not gonna walk off set.
Yeah, real mature.
(laughter)